nearly 200 dead 14 000 who are sick
millions as you witness who are scared
right now what do you say to americans
who are watching you right now
who are scared i say that you're a
terrible reporter that's what i say
when we go on hunts we run out of
animals we chase her
i'm full i'm exciting and i'm different
well i'll agree with the third you take
me back to elementary school
i say my abc's to you see i give you an
a because you're awesome
i give you a b because you beautiful i
give you a c because you're confident
and i give you this d because uh you
deserve it
but it's been a great year i learned
there's a whole other olson i found that
out this year that's awesome
where were they hiding her huh she's the
best one
come on it's crazy
this is amazing i can't believe she was
the mistake it was uh
and england skipper andrew strauss
arrived in london proudly showing off
the little urn
they'll spend four days at home before
flying out
for the world cup and belinda i just
can't understand how something so small
can be
so impressive well mark you would know
about that thank you very much
first off i want to say i agree with you
sebastian i really am a fond of the uh
the winter soldier star
um and if uh anthony if you ever need
any resistance training for that leg day
let me know
what did you think about nikki and
cardi's uh
altercation at fashion week were you you
were at that party right
no it was called the icon party but
there were no icons there
everybody was saying i was doing dancing
guitars and like they never asked me
so yeah i don't know why they did that
would you
um probably like 10 years in 10 years
well not 10 years but i feel like you
should be on dancing
stars when you fall off oh when you fall
off so i don't know
i only say that oh no you're on it
and i love the black people we need you
people i swear because no jew is going
to make up a train
uh what was this award for i'm sorry
huh oh
oh viewers choice oh my god y'all thank
you
you don't really act you don't sing you
don't dance
you don't have any forgive me any talent
but we're still entertaining people
but as i say i'm gonna be nice tonight
i've changed
not as much as bruce jenner obviously
now caitlyn jenner of course what a year
she's had
she became a role model for trans people
everywhere showing great bravery
in breaking down barriers and destroying
stereotypes
she didn't do a lot for women drivers
but
lies that many of you are still at home
but if you are heading out this weekend
there is some
weekend construction you need to be
aware of our new traffic anchor anavid
reyes has a look at this weekend's
traffic
yes veronica we are out here live we're
at exit 57
on i-24 east if you're looking at
traffic don't expect too many delays as
you can see out here things look
to be moving along just fine over my
left shoulder you can see
some minor road construction in the area
but that hasn't affected things
much this morning and oh by the way just
real quick my name is pronounced a navid
not naveed so if i'm going to come out
here and do these live traffic reports
and literally risk my life i'd
appreciate if somebody back in the
studio could learn how to pronounce my
name oh i'm sorry
you got it navi whose idea was it for
the fake pregnancy
well i mean when you're having fake sex
then you have fake babies
yeah well you know what you may have
been having fake sex on your side of the
bed but on my side i was tearing that
this lady is my wife you should be
ashamed
if this lady is your life you should be
ashamed back here on 120 minutes i'm
thurston moore of sonic youth
interviewing beck who's right here
beside me
back uh i sort of wanted to ask you some
questions about uh
you know where you're from and who
exactly you are
and i can't seem to get any straight
answers out of anybody who
seems to know you but uh what exactly is
your
real name is it beck were you christened
back
all right warren what the hell are you
doing here
holy [ __ ] warren was he was great on
dancing with the stars he came in second
and then celebrated by dragging his
partner to the top of the empire state
building
but are you still considered the fat guy
when you go to a party or anything
because i run into that a whole lot
i'm the fat one so does that are you the
fat guy in hollywood still or
or does everybody like look at you and
they're like oh wow you know this is
great now you're healthy
uh do you have any other questions that
are smart things are clearly going
brilliantly in your career i just
wondered if you are as happy in your
private life
and will we be seeing our certain mr
ashton kutcher perhaps making a trip
over here wow how disappointing was that
question
should we move on to another one
absolutely i think that was the quest
we've got to move on i think i'm happy
and i'm single if that's what you're
really asking
as used in the sentence the shopkeeper
enunciated i'm sorry rachel but we only
have that particular dress
in a child size
save zombie 80 you'd know all about that
jimmy saves on v18 my kid sammy
you're a black man i took a guess
if you ain't black you fell into a
bucket of m m's
everybody want to know what i would do
if i didn't win
i guess we'll never know
i came in and he was supposed to be the
uh my uh
kind of my guide through snl and it
turned out
that he is a [ __ ] stir
i'm not gonna guide any lady through
comedy that would take me uh
first of all i'd have to figure out how
a lady could do comment
last week we had mariah carey here in
the studio you did
how was she doing well uh she was doing
great oh great yes
it's great what i'm curious about what
do you think of her what do i think of
her yes
i don't think of her i
one hollywood publication said that me
hosting would mean
that some film stars would stay away for
fear of being made fun of
as if film starts to stay away from the
chance of winning a golden globe
particularly if their film company has
already paid for it
shaq man you look good you look good
congratulations you're
you're uh your knuckles have scraped did
you walk here
[Applause]
and the other was i met adele you you
met adele oh
yeah a lovely woman oh yeah
[Applause]
oh no no she's thin can we just talk to
each other here
you know what what is this song uh
rolling in the deep she should add fried
chicken
it is ralphie mae
of course is here uh ralphie you like
the population of india you're loud
sweaty and double in size every year
rob served in afghanistan before
becoming a stand-up comic
then the real bombing began
can you tell me the price of this bed
eight thousand dollars well that's
preposterous
i can get the same bid anywhere in town
for 25 yes but not with me in it
name a number that most men exaggerate
100 69
[Applause]
during our sex scene i felt your dick
rubbing
okay talking of the walking dead
congratulations to hugh hefner who uh
is getting married at the age of 84
to 24 year old beauty crystal harris um
when she was asked why she was marrying
him she said because he lied about his
age
he told me he was 94. oh come on
um don't worry
hold out and just just don't look at it
when you touch it
so have you seen the movies like you
have to you have to know all the movies
i've watched some of them yeah you know
some of them any clunkers anything you
like you don't like that
you know they're good there's some good
ones yeah
yeah what are you trying to get me to
say man
that goes without saying but anything
anything
hey you did a movie too i don't i know
i'm i i know i did a lot your movie went
straight to audio
he was wonderful in that dwayne's got a
tattoo right above his ass that says
come on
sugar ray is a great champion sugar we'd
ask you to talk but you know the blacks
your lips locked
you're the one i've seen in my dreams
you want to hear the course no i
couldn't hear anymore okay
best singer in america oh yeah right i
can honestly say
you are the worst singer in america
truthfully that's my first audition well
i'm not surprised it should be your last
that way last time at the first debate
we had millions of people
uh fact checking so i expect we'll have
millions more fact checking
uh because you know it is uh
it's just awfully good that someone with
the temperament of donald trump is not
in charge
of the law in our country because you'd
be in jail
secretary clinton
yeah and people love to laugh i mean
that's why people love you
but they also know that you you know you
have some shock value to you i mean
you're on the cover
of your book you're wearing a fur and
you knew that there would probably be
animal rights acting you know this whole
interview is becoming a defensive
interview
are you wearing leather shoes yes
you know what i mean i don't want to
hear you're wearing fur
you're wearing i'm not an actor you're
eating chicken you're eating meat i
don't want to hear this nonsense
i just wanted to show the legs because
as i was telling you ahead of time
you're going to walk home with more than
maybe just a trophy tonight i think lots
of men
i'm not gonna walk home with any men
tonight i'm gonna i'm gonna go hang out
with my friends
and then i go home to the cat did i
scare you guys
finally an attractive guest
yes you did scare us i never screamed
like that in real life you know i was
already
only in the bedroom
well you would never know but let me ask
you
of course women should be paid the same
as men for doing the same job
and i'd like to say now that i'm getting
paid exactly the same
as tina and amy did last year for
hosting
no i know there was two of them but it's
not my fault if they want to share the
money is
how many of you were at who was at the
funeral i was at the funeral
funeral yeah funeral yeah were you at
the funerals and dan
no no no no no they weren't invited jake
was not the funeral
this is how bad it is for me i was told
it was a wedding
[Laughter]
no word of a lie i showed up to the
wedding very solid wedding
coffee areas and i was like where's
river
remember the words of a great negro i
say that honestly
all peoples are alike we are all working
you live in my neighborhood i live in
yours right sam right
are you crazy
i'll send you a new uh show where you
sit in the hot tub
your body ain't that good you can just
walk around without your shirt off
if we're ever gonna talk about bodies i
want you not to be the one to bring that
conversation
all right if you don't get out of here
shaped like a bean bag they got that
thanks for having me you know i uh i was
so excited to be here and see
shaq and emma and hang out with all
these comedians i feel like i died and
went to harlem
this ain't a roast it's a barbecue
and you're still looking like cher
[Music]
well she looks good for her age unlike
some people
i can see you right now in the kitchen
bending over a hot stove
but i can't see the stove and coulter if
you're here who's scaring the crows away
from our crops